[Music]
banking isn't like the old days anymore
inflation is rising at the fastest pace
in decades and government bond yields
the highest they've been in years but
banks still aren't paying customers any
more for their deposits
don't expect that to change anytime soon
i want to explain why banks are defying
the historical trend of higher interest
rates meaning higher savings rates why
they're likely to continue paying next
to nothing for savings and what we're
seeing some investors do with their
savings in this environment let's get
into it
to start let me give you some context
the average rate on a savings account at
large u.s banks is only about
0.06 percent now that made sense when
u.s government interest rates were low
in 2020 and 2021
but today the gap between treasury rates
and savings rates is just enormous
historically banks paid higher interest
on savings accounts when the rates on
government bonds rose but today even
though the interest payment on a
one-year bond from the u.s government
has risen from the equivalent of .06 a
year ago to well over one percent bank
savings rates haven't moved
now that means banks can take customers
deposits put them in u.s government
bonds which are considered risk-free
assets and earn a return of more than 20
times their investment but why aren't
banks raising rates on savings accounts
now banks are able to keep savings rates
low because they've got so much cash
already the personal savings rate jumped
through the pandemic
total deposits at u.s commercial banks
have swelled to more than 18 trillion
dollars from just over 13 trillion at
the start of 2020 but customers aren't
demanding higher rates they haven't
pulled their money out of the big banks
like chase city or wells fargo even
though some upstart banks are offering
interest rates 10 times higher than the
big guys and banks probably aren't going
to raise rates in the future in the
olden days banks had to pay high savings
rates to attract deposits they would
lend that money out at a higher rate for
things like mortgages and credit cards
but that's changed in recent years as
more money has flowed into banks and
those banks have found fewer attractive
options for making loans since congress
passed the cares act in 2020 americans
have failed increased savings and many
are stashing it in banks even though
they're earning next to nothing in part
because the federal reserve has held u.s
interest rates close to zero for much of
the past decade folks have just gotten
used to not getting anything for their
savings the fed has also flooded the
market with cash on the bank side
they're looking to make money and very
few loans can offer the kind of return
that banks can earn from investing their
customers deposits in stocks bonds and
other assets plus there's been a decline
in demand for loans as many small
businesses were wiped out by the
coronavirus pandemic
this is basic supply and demand
right now there's a ton of money being
supplied to banks without a
corresponding increase in demand
that lowers value even for something
like money the result of all that is
big banks are getting americans money
for next to nothing and they're able to
earn high rates of return with
historically low risk
you can see why they're earning record
profits seemingly every quarter savvy
investors are pulling their money out of
traditional savings accounts the real
savings rate which is the difference
between an average interest rate on a us
savings account and the rate of
inflation was the most negative it has
ever been in february negative 7.8
that environment is pushing many
americans to take more risk some are
taking out loans and using that money as
a substitute for their savings for
everyday retail investors that can be a
personal or home equity loan from a bank
or a margin loan from their investment
account
they're putting their money in stocks
and other investments and keeping that
borrowed money at the ready in case of
emergencies
professional investors are taking out
margin loans as well and buying treasury
futures or using options contracts to
substitute for cash
investors who can afford it are also
pumping their money into real estate
buying homes and commercial properties
this has been a major contributor to the
extreme run up in housing prices make no
mistake these are risky strategies but
many see that risk as a better option
than having their money eroded by
inflation at the fastest rate in history
it remains to be seen just how high
interest rates can go without banks
giving their customers a bump in their
savings rate but until americans start
demanding higher rates
banks aren't going to pay them if you
enjoyed this video hit the like button
and make sure to subscribe if you're
interested in markets and want to see
more videos like this one as ohio
hip-hop legend stally tells us no
surprise in your eyes when you see us
touch the sky with no leer jets if money
call we pop right up like a fair catch
see you next time
[Music]
you